Now, let me show you a simple feature,
matching demo,
to kind of demonstrate how we can
do this kind of feature detection.
To show you this demo,
let's go to the Sandbox.
Again, remember,
it's always going to have the last code
that you had played around with, and
here, I'm basically putting in the code
to help us do feature detection.
Again, setting up numpy and cv2, and all
of that stuff, some code to draw things.
Look for things in there and
read an image.
Now, one thing I want to point out,
we're using a special
variant on SIFT called orb.
That's what we're going to be using.
You should be able to, in your own
setup space, if you have all configured
correctly with open CVN python,
be able to actually use a Sift, also.
I encourage you to look at documentation
of Sift on open CV to try that.
So basically again, in this process,
we come up with the whole
process to find the key points.
We draw them, which is shown here,
and then we actually run a matching
algorithm to be able to
match these types of things.
And once these matches are appearing,
we will print them out, and
then of course, show the matches.
So let’s run.
Okay, it’s pointing out the image sizes.
It found 500 key points in the two
images, and found 257 matches.
These are the two images.
This one and this one.
This is the box cover itself directly,
and this box,
again here, with conclusions and
all shown there.
Of course, now, if you notice that I
actually did a lot of computation to
find all of those features
on both of these images,
lots of colors here, and once it found
those features, it matched them.
So now,
I was starting to put this here, and
if you notice, all of the visible
parts that were there, here,
were matched between the image here and
this one image here.
So this showcases how
this could be done, and
this showcased the whole
code is right above here.
I will even share with you this code so
you can actually play
around with it yourself.